Sponsored by Newport Healthcare providing results-driven treatment for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28 who are struggling with trauma, depression, anxiety, and other mood, personality, and co-occurring disorders. At Newport Healthcare, tailored treatment plans foster sustainable healing to help young people move from struggling to thriving. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com. Dissociative identity disorder is one of Hollywood's favorite psychology-related topics. movies such as the strange case of Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde and the Three Faces of Eve to this spring's Moon Night TV series, filmmakers and the public have long been fascinated by what used to be called multiple personality disorder. And that's not surprising. The idea that multiple personalities could exist in one person's mind has obvious dramatic potential and might even
本节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，为12至28岁受创伤、抑郁、焦虑及其他情绪、人格和共病障碍困扰的青少年和年轻人提供以结果为导向的治疗。在Newport Healthcare，量身定制的治疗方案旨在促进可持续的康复，帮助年轻人从挣扎走向蓬勃发展。详情请访问newporthealthcare.com。解离性身份障碍是好莱坞最钟爱的心理学话题之一。从《化身博士》和《三面夏娃》等电影，到今年春季的电视剧《月光骑士》，电影制作人和公众长期以来一直对这种曾经被称为多重人格障碍的疾病着迷。这并不令人惊讶。多重人格可能存在于一个人大脑中的想法具有明显的戏剧潜力，甚至可能
feel familiar to some of us. But in real life, dissociative identity disorder does not look like it does on the screen or in books. According to some researchers, it is both more common and more subtle than fictional portrayals would lead us to believe. Meanwhile, its causes and treatments remain controversial among many mental health researchers and practitioners. So what is dissociative identity disorder? How common is it and what causes it? What is happening in the brains of patients who experience it? What treatments are available and how well do they work? And is there any truth at all to be found in its many portrayals in movies, in literature, and on TV. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
对我们中的一些人来说感到熟悉。但在现实生活中，解离性身份障碍并不像电影或书中描述的那样。据一些研究人员称，它比虚构作品让我们相信的要普遍得多，也微妙得多。与此同时，其成因和治疗方法在许多心理健康研究人员和从业者中仍存在争议。那么，什么是解离性身份障碍？它有多普遍？成因是什么？患有此病的患者大脑中发生了什么？有哪些治疗方法？效果如何？它在电影、文学和电视中的许多描述有真实成分吗？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Bethany Brand, a clinical psychologist and professor of psychology at Towson University in Maryland. An expert in trauma, she specializes in the assessment and treatment of trauma-related disorders, including dissociative disorders. She has published dozens of research papers on dissociative and other trauma disorders, and she is the principal investigator of the largest prospective treatment outcome study to date
该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是Kim Mills。我们今天的嘉宾是Bethany Brand博士，她是马里兰州陶森大学的临床心理学家和心理学教授。作为创伤领域的专家，她专门从事创伤相关障碍（包括解离性障碍）的评估和治疗。她发表了数十篇关于解离和其他创伤障碍的研究论文，并且是迄今为止规模最大的前瞻性治疗结果研究的首席研究员
of dissociative disorders called T-O-P-D-D. She also maintains a private practice focused on assessing and treating patients with trauma disorders, and she has served as an expert in a variety of trauma-related forensic cases. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Brandt. Thank you very much for having me. Many of our listeners know dissociative identity disorder by its old name, multiple personality disorder and may not recognize the term dissociative identity disorder or DID. So let's start with the definition.
该研究名为T-O-P-D-D，专门针对解离性障碍。她还经营着一家私人诊所，专注于评估和治疗创伤障碍患者，并曾在各种创伤相关的法医案件中担任专家。感谢您今天加入我们，Brandt博士。非常感谢邀请我。我们的许多听众通过旧称“多重人格障碍”来了解解离性身份障碍，可能不熟悉“解离性身份障碍”或DID这个术语。所以，让我们从定义开始。
What is DID? And more broadly, what is dissociation and how does it relate to the disorder? Dissociative identity disorder is one of the five dissociative disorders in the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental illnesses. So let's start with dissociation, which is, well, we can all experience some dissociation. So if we're driving down the highway and just preoccupied, we may not remember much of the drive once we get home or we may even miss our exit. That's normal non-pathological dissociation. More pathological dissociation occurs when somebody has experienced very serious trauma, often childhood trauma that's repetitive, so that they learn over time to, disconnect. That's what dissociation really is. It's a disconnection or disintegration of what are
什么是DID？更广泛地说，什么是解离，它与这种障碍有什么关系？解离性身份障碍是《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中五种解离性障碍之一。让我们从解离开始，其实我们每个人都可能经历过某种程度的解离。比如，当我们开车在高速公路上行驶时，如果心不在焉，到家后可能记不清开车的过程，甚至可能错过出口。这是正常的非病理性解离。更具病理性的解离发生在某人经历过非常严重的创伤时，通常是反复发生的童年创伤，以至于他们随着时间的推移学会了“断开连接”。这就是解离的本质。它是对
normally psychologically integrated functions. So the person may disconnect from their emotions. They don't feel anything, even though they would normally feel terrified, for example. They disconnect from their body. They may not feel as much pain. And so you can understand how, in the case of trauma, especially that's very physically painful trauma or emotionally painful trauma, or both, if a child or an adult disconnects from themselves, their body, their emotions, or if they disconnect from their memory, it would help somewhat dull the pain, if you will. It doesn't mean that then trauma is not traumatic, because of course it still is, but over time, if that happens again and again and again, the child, because DID is a developmentally based
正常心理整合功能的断开或解体。因此，一个人可能会与自己的情绪断开连接。即使在通常情况下会感到恐惧，他们也可能什么都感觉不到。他们会与自己的身体断开连接，可能感觉不到那么强烈的疼痛。因此，你可以理解，在创伤的情况下，特别是身体上非常痛苦或情感上非常痛苦的创伤，或者两者兼有，如果一个孩子或成年人与自己、身体、情绪或记忆断开连接，这在某种程度上会有助于减轻痛苦。这并不意味着创伤本身不再具有创伤性，因为它当然仍然是，但如果这种情况反复发生，孩子（因为DID是一种基于发育的
trauma disorder, it starts in very early childhood. So typically there's abuse that's occurring before age six, and it's repetitive. And so the child learns again and again and again to disconnect from themselves so that over time, those memories of those traumatic events are not integrated into normal memory. And the child may not always recall it. And so eventually they have different states that develop where they don't have to think about that horrible stuff all the time. And they can go to school and seem seemingly normal, like nothing horrible. horrible happened just in advance of school that day or the night before. And so it's adaptive in
创伤障碍）会在很小的童年时期就开始。通常，虐待发生在六岁之前，并且是反复发生的。因此，孩子一次又一次地学会与自己断开连接，以至于随着时间的推移，那些创伤事件的记忆并没有整合到正常的记忆中。孩子可能并不总是能回忆起这些。最终，他们发展出了不同的状态，这样他们就不必一直去想那些可怕的事情。他们可以去上学，看起来似乎很正常，就像那天上学前或前一天晚上没有发生任何可怕的事情一样。因此，这在
the time during which the trauma is occurring. But over time, it's actually a disorder associated with all kinds of suffering. To go back just to the definition, by definition in that diagnostic manual, the person has to have two or more different, I'm going to call them dissociative self-states, but other authors, other times people refer to them as identities or parts or altars. And those parts can take control of their behavior. And at least some of the time they don't remember what they did in a different state. So there's dissociative amnesia for at least some of that behavior in different states. So as I mentioned in the introduction, there's a long history of literature, movies, and TV portrayals of this phenomenon.
创伤发生的当时是一种适应性机制。但随着时间的推移，它实际上是一种与各种痛苦相关的障碍。回到定义，根据诊断手册的定义，患者必须有两个或更多不同的——我称之为解离性自我状态，但其他作者有时称之为身份、部分或人格面具。这些部分可以控制他们的行为。至少在某些时候，他们不记得自己在另一种状态下做了什么。因此，在不同状态下的某些行为中存在解离性失忆。正如我在介绍中提到的，关于这种现象的文学、电影和电视描述有着悠久的历史。
And now it's back in the spotlight again with this TV show, Moon Night. How well do you think these portrayals of DID over the years have reflected the reality of the disorder? Has it ever been portrayed well on screen or in books? I think they're almost always abysmal, stigmatized, stereotyped versions of the disorder, more so than just about any disorder out there. Men tend to be portrayed as serial killers, monsters, women can be portrayed that way, but more often, as sex fiends. I'm actually doing a study on this right now to ask people living with DID, how have they been impacted by these media portrayals? And the stories, the quotes that we're getting back are just so painful. Like, you know, they hated themselves. They didn't want
现在，随着电视剧《月光骑士》的播出，它再次成为焦点。你认为多年来这些对DID的描述在多大程度上反映了这种疾病的现实？它在银幕或书中是否曾被很好地刻画过？我认为它们几乎总是糟糕的、带有污名化和刻板印象的描述，比任何其他疾病都要严重。男性往往被描绘成连环杀手或怪物，女性也可能被这样描绘，但更多时候是被描绘成性狂。我目前正在对此进行一项研究，询问DID患者，这些媒体描述对他们有何影响？我们收到的故事和引述非常令人心碎。比如，他们讨厌自己。他们甚至不想
even their clinicians, their mental health professionals to know about the disorder. And in some cases, even the professionals were scared of them because of these stereotypes. They're very damaging. And in the movies, D.I.D. is often shown as a dramatic and a sudden switch between personalities. Is that what it looks like in real life to an observer? I'm so glad you're asking me that, because that occurs in less than 5% of cases. So, of course, the media has to show these dramatic shifts that, you know, somebody comes in talking and baby talk, and then the next time they come in swaggering and a cigarette draped out of their mouth. So that's so the audience can figure it out. If If DID really look like that, it wouldn't be so underdiagnosed and misdiagnosed.
让他们的临床医生或心理健康专业人员知道这种疾病。在某些情况下，甚至专业人员也会因为这些刻板印象而害怕他们。这些描述非常有破坏性。在电影中，DID通常被表现为人格之间戏剧性且突然的转换。在现实生活中，观察者看到的是这样吗？我很高兴你问我这个问题，因为这种情况在不到5%的病例中发生。当然，媒体必须展示这些戏剧性的转变，比如某人进来时用婴儿语说话，下一次进来时却大摇大摆，嘴里叼着烟。这是为了让观众能看懂。如果DID真的看起来那样，它就不会被如此低估和误诊了。
It's often misdiagnosed as schizophrenia because more than 75% of people who have DID hear voices or it's misdiagnosed, for example, as bipolar disorder because there's these mood shifts. They look like moody people. Now, neither of those disorders have amnesia associated and they're not trauma disorders. So it's not, DID is not at all schizophrenia. It's not at all bipolar disorder. and those media portrayals obviously contribute to some of the reason why there's so much under-diagnosis of D-I-D. So how do patients describe the experience to you?
它经常被误诊为精神分裂症，因为超过75%的DID患者会听到声音；或者被误诊为双相情感障碍，因为他们有情绪波动，看起来像喜怒无常的人。然而，这两种疾病都没有相关的失忆症，也不是创伤性障碍。所以，DID根本不是精神分裂症，也不是双相情感障碍。这些媒体描述显然是导致DID被严重低估的原因之一。那么，患者是如何向你描述这种体验的？
Are they aware that they're shifting from one altar to another? They vary tremendously when they come in for treatment. Typically, when a person who actually has D.I.D. comes in for treatment, they tend to come in with reports of severe crushing depression that hasn't responded to any medications or previous trials of psychotherapy. They often have post-traumatic stress disorder. They tend to be aware of that. They may have a substance abuse problem. They may have an eating disorder. They have problems with sleep. Every so often, there are people who come in and they're aware or they think they are aware of having dissociative states. But that's actually not so common. Although with all the social media that's out there now,
他们意识到自己正在从一个“人格面具”切换到另一个吗？当他们来接受治疗时，情况各不相同。通常，真正患有DID的人来接受治疗时，往往伴随着严重的、压倒性的抑郁，且对任何药物或之前的心理治疗尝试都没有反应。他们通常患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。他们往往意识到这一点。他们可能有药物滥用问题，可能有饮食失调，有睡眠问题。偶尔，有些人来的时候意识到或认为自己意识到有解离状态。但这实际上并不常见。尽管现在社交媒体很发达，
more people are sometimes coming in, at least in my experience, I've been in the field for about 30 years. And I do have some people who have come in and said, I think I have this. And I proceed to do a standardized assessment and find out if it's accurate or not. They're often very embarrassed about their mood, well, their mood changes, but even more importantly, the lapses they have in memory. Imagine you or I, we don't know somebody who greets us on the street, who obviously knows us, calls us by name, and is referring to a conversation or an interaction we've had, you know, it would be mortifying. They have that happen a lot. And so it's embarrassing and they try and cover that up like anybody else. Anytime anybody else covers up something we've done that feels
据我的经验，我从事这个领域大约30年了，更多的人有时会来咨询，有些人说：“我想我有这个病。”然后我进行标准化评估，看看是否准确。他们通常对自己的情绪变化感到非常尴尬，但更重要的是，他们对记忆缺失感到尴尬。想象一下，你或我，在街上遇到一个打招呼的人，对方显然认识我们，叫出我们的名字，并提到我们进行过的对话或互动，这会让人感到非常羞愧。他们经常发生这种情况。所以这很尴尬，他们像其他人一样试图掩盖它。任何人在掩盖我们所做的感到
embarrassing. As you mentioned, there are tests. There are ways that you determine whether people actually have this disorder. How do you assess patients for dissociative disorders and then what kinds of treatments are available. Sad to say, but most mental health professionals have not been trained in assessing dissociative disorders. They don't even know that much about dissociation. At the start of the hour, you talked about how there's some controversy about dissociation and dissociative disorders.
尴尬的事情时都会这样做。正如你提到的，有测试方法。有方法可以确定人们是否真的患有这种疾病。你如何评估解离性障碍患者，有哪些治疗方法可用？遗憾的是，大多数心理健康专业人员没有接受过评估解离性障碍的培训。他们甚至对解离了解不多。在节目开始时，你谈到了关于解离和解离性障碍的争议。
And so that's one of the factors that leads to many graduate programs, medical schools, not doing training about it. So first of all, a person would need to go to somebody who's had training in assessing dissociation. And I'm currently actually writing a book for the American Psychological Association on assessing dissociation. It is the first book that's ever been written solely about the multiple ways you assess for it. So that shows you how far behind our field is and really learning about assessing dissociation. There are a number of scientifically validated self-report questionnaires that a clinician could use. There are also
这就是导致许多研究生项目和医学院不进行相关培训的因素之一。因此，首先，一个人需要去找受过解离评估培训的人。我目前正在为美国心理学会写一本关于评估解离的书。这是第一本专门讨论评估解离的多种方法的书。这表明我们的领域在学习评估解离方面落后了多少。临床医生可以使用许多经过科学验证的自我报告问卷。还有
standardized evidence-based interviews, structured clinical interviews for dissociative disorders, and hopefully a clinician would use one or more of those tools to make an accurate diagnosis. It can also be done without those tools, but then there's more errors. You know, there's just more errors. Like when doctors do blood tests, you've got a greater chance of getting an accurate diagnosis and the same thing with mental health conditions, especially this one, because it really can sound like and seem like different disorders. And then what are the treatments that are available?
标准化的循证访谈，即解离性障碍结构化临床访谈，希望临床医生能使用其中一种或多种工具来做出准确的诊断。没有这些工具也可以进行诊断，但错误率会更高。你知道，就是会有更多错误。就像医生做血液检查一样，你获得准确诊断的机会更大，心理健康状况也是如此，尤其是这种疾病，因为它听起来和看起来确实像不同的疾病。那么有哪些治疗方法可用呢？
It tends to be a longer term trauma-based, trauma-informed treatment where there's three stages, roughly speaking. When the client first comes in, they tend to be struggling with profound depression, like I mentioned, but also many of these folks have a lot of self-harm, like cutting or burning, and they often are in research terms. The research is clear they are some of the most suicidal clients in the mental health field. So there needs to be a lot of stabilization. So they need some help, for example.
这往往是一种长期的、基于创伤的、创伤知情的治疗，大致分为三个阶段。当客户刚来时，他们往往像我提到的那样，正处于严重的抑郁中，而且这些人中许多人有严重的自残行为，比如割伤或烧伤，在研究术语中，研究很清楚，他们是心理健康领域自杀倾向最高的客户之一。因此，需要大量的稳定化工作。所以他们需要一些帮助，例如。
I talked about problems with sleep. If you don't sleep, you don't do well in the day. But because nights were oftentimes where trauma occurred or they have nightmares, they're terrified of sleep. and they're hyper aroused. Their nervous system is jacked up because of all the trauma and the flashbacks and the nightmares. And so helping them get their sleep regulated, helping them get any self-harm or suicidal thoughts under control, helping them learn not to dissociate so much their what's called losing time.
我谈到了睡眠问题。如果你睡不好，白天就无法正常工作。但因为夜晚往往是创伤发生的时候，或者他们有噩梦，他们害怕睡觉。他们处于过度觉醒状态。由于所有的创伤、闪回和噩梦，他们的神经系统处于高度紧张状态。因此，帮助他们调节睡眠，帮助他们控制自残或自杀念头，帮助他们学会不要过度解离——也就是所谓的“失去时间”。
They're having those gaps in memory. So you're basically doing a lot of teaching tools that help the person manage their symptoms, function day to day. And also another thing is addressing profound shame, self-hatred, and taking it out on themselves, basically. That's through the self-harm, for example. And so you do a lot to try and educate them about the impact of trauma. So they don't feel like they're just, you know, this evil, awful person, but they understand the things they're struggling with are symptoms. Anyway, all of that is stage one, stabilization and safety. if they get stable, and there are some folks that that's the stage they stay at.
他们会出现记忆空白。所以你基本上是在做大量的教学工具，帮助个人管理症状，进行日常运作。另一个方面是解决深层的羞耻感、自我厌恶，以及基本上对自己进行伤害。例如，通过自残。所以你要做很多工作来尝试教育他们创伤的影响。这样他们就不会觉得自己是一个邪恶、糟糕的人，而是明白他们所挣扎的事情是症状。总之，所有这些都是第一阶段：稳定和安全。如果他们稳定下来，有些人会停留在这一阶段。
But if they get stabilized and they want to move on to actually processing the trauma, that stage two work, so having them start with talking about and working through their traumas, like with other trauma-focused treatments, but less emphasis on just going over traumas as intensively. The pacing has to be done carefully because they've gone through so much trauma. And so this is, again, where a clinician really needs to know what they're doing and needs to have training and treating traumatized, especially dissociative clients, because you don't want to flood somebody. And if that happens, they can get more symptomatic. So that's the trauma processing and grieving stage. There's a ton of grief that goes along with that as they recognize and work through all these traumas.
但如果他们稳定下来并希望继续进行创伤处理，那就是第二阶段的工作：让他们开始谈论并处理他们的创伤，就像其他以创伤为中心的治疗一样，但重点不再是仅仅密集地回顾创伤。节奏必须小心把握，因为他们经历过太多的创伤。所以，这再次体现了临床医生必须知道自己在做什么，并且需要接受过治疗受创伤者（尤其是解离性客户）的培训，因为你不想让某人被情绪淹没。如果发生这种情况，他们的症状可能会加重。这就是创伤处理和哀悼阶段。当他们认识到并处理所有这些创伤时，会伴随着大量的悲伤。
it's incredibly painful. One thing I didn't mention, when they have DID, they have these dissociative self-states. So throughout this process, they need to be gradually getting to know their parts and understanding all of those parts of them and learning to gradually shift from sort of parts fighting each other, which is often the case when they first come in, to gradually learning to cooperate and collaborate and work more smoothly so that the whole person's functioning. is supported and it's not just one against another. And then the third stage is, you know, there's less focus on trauma and it's more on, you know, living a full life, having healthy relationships, you know,
这极其痛苦。有一件事我没提到，当他们患有DID时，他们有这些解离性自我状态。因此，在整个过程中，他们需要逐渐了解自己的部分，理解所有这些部分，并学习逐渐从通常刚来时那种部分之间相互争斗的状态，转变为逐渐学会合作、协作，更顺畅地工作，从而支持整个人格的运作，而不是一个部分对抗另一个部分。然后第三阶段是，减少对创伤的关注，更多地关注过上充实的生活，建立健康的关系，
establishing or furthering their career, that sort of thing. And is any drug therapy involved as part of this? Because most of them have very serious depression, very serious anxiety, very seriously problems. There's often, there are many of these individuals are on a cocktail of antipsychotics. Sometimes it's not that they're psychotic, but to help calm them, they may be used. It's more common for them to have antidepressants and something that helps with anti-anxiety medications. There's a class of those called benzodiazepines that are addictive. There's mixed feelings about using those long term. a lot of people, of course, you know, don't want clients to be on those long-term, but there are some other types of anti-anxiety medications that are not addictive.
建立或推进他们的职业生涯，等等。这其中涉及药物治疗吗？因为他们大多数人有非常严重的抑郁、非常严重的焦虑和非常严重的问题。通常，许多这些人服用抗精神病药物组合。有时并不是因为他们有精神病，而是为了帮助他们冷静下来。他们更常服用抗抑郁药和有助于抗焦虑的药物。有一类药物叫苯二氮卓类，容易上瘾。对于长期使用这些药物存在不同意见。当然，很多人不希望客户长期服用这些药物，但还有其他类型的抗焦虑药物不会上瘾。
And so it's very common for them to have, you know, several medications that they're taking. None of them, there is no medication that's antidesociative. So we've got antidepressants, anti-anxiety, antipsychotics. We don't have an anti-dissociative. Sponsored by Newport Healthcare, dedicated to providing sustainable healing for young people struggling with mental health concerns so they can move from self-destruction to self-esteem. Based in compassion and driven by outcomes, Newport serves teens and young adults ages 12 to 28 at residential and outpatient programs nationwide. Through tailored treatment and family support, Newport successfully addresses
因此，他们服用几种药物是非常普遍的。没有一种药物是“抗解离”的。所以我们有抗抑郁药、抗焦虑药、抗精神病药。我们没有抗解离药。本节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，致力于为受心理健康问题困扰的年轻人提供可持续的康复，使他们能从自我毁灭走向自我尊重。Newport以同情心为基础，以结果为导向，在全国范围内的住院和门诊项目中为12至28岁的青少年和年轻人提供服务。通过量身定制的治疗和家庭支持，Newport成功解决了
psychological and behavioral issues, including depression, anxiety, personality disorders, and substance abuse. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com. I understand that there are some people who have other mental conditions who may pretend to have dissociative identity disorder. And certainly there's the infamous story that became the book, Sybil, and was later a movie starring Sally Field that some of our listeners may have seen. How can a clinician tell if someone is faking it? So one of my lines of research has been on establishing data across various tests, psychological tests, Some are what are called malingering test, and they're supposed to pick up on the possibility of malingering. And I have, with students in my lab, we have developed data that shows this is what genuine patients with DID score on these various tests,
包括抑郁、焦虑、人格障碍和药物滥用在内的心理和行为问题。详情请访问newporthealthcare.com。据我了解，有些人患有其他精神疾病，可能会假装患有解离性身份障碍。当然，还有那个臭名昭著的故事，后来变成了书《西比尔》，后来又拍成了由莎莉·菲尔德主演的电影，我们的一些听众可能看过。临床医生如何判断某人是否在装病？我的研究方向之一是建立各种心理测试的数据，有些被称为“诈病测试”，它们旨在发现诈病的可能性。我和实验室的学生已经开发出数据，显示真正的DID患者在这些测试中的得分情况，
and here's what people who are imitating faking DID score, and this is how you distinguish them. So there is evidence that helps a whole body of evidence across, I forget, six or seven or eight tests nowadays. where we've shown ways to distinguish the two. And also if clinicians use those evidence-based measures I was talking about earlier, that helps them have some idea of how does this person's report of symptoms compare to other people who have dissociative disorders. So it goes back again to know the science, follow the science, and use the science. And clearly there's a need for the book you're working on.
以及模仿或假装DID的人的得分情况，这就是区分他们的方法。因此，有证据可以帮助建立一个完整的证据体系，涵盖我忘记是六、七还是八种测试。我们已经展示了区分两者的途径。此外，如果临床医生使用我之前提到的那些循证测量工具，这有助于他们了解这个人的症状报告与其他患有解离性障碍的人相比如何。所以这又回到了：了解科学，遵循科学，利用科学。显然，你正在写的书非常有必要。
Thank you. Yes, I think so. Let's hope I get my deadline on time. So, you know, there's been a lot of advancement in the study of psychological disorders through brain imaging. And I'm wondering, has much brain imaging been done with people who have DID and do their brains look markedly different? Yes, there are three labs that are working on that in particular. There's, I'm sure, other labs as well. But there's a Harvard lab working on this. Ruth Lannius up in Ontario is working on it and a woman in the Netherlands and her team.
谢谢。是的，我也这么认为。希望我能按时完成截止日期。那么，通过脑成像，心理障碍的研究取得了很大进展。我想知道，是否对DID患者进行了大量的脑成像研究？他们的大脑看起来有显著不同吗？是的，有三个实验室正在特别研究这个问题。当然还有其他实验室。哈佛大学有一个实验室在研究这个。安大略省的Ruth Lannius也在研究，荷兰的一位女性和她的团队也在研究。
And there's a couple of other people in the Netherlands. And summarizing very briefly, they are seeing that there are brain network patterns that distinguish people who are highly dissociative from those who have what is what I'm going to refer to as classic or simple PTSD, post-traumatic stress disorder. So there's now in the more recent diagnostic manual, there's dissociative PTSD and regular PTSD. And the dissociative folks, as it might sound like, they tend to, when they go in the brain scanner, for example, and hear their trauma stories read to them while they're in the brain scanner. So they're essentially having a flashback and they're warned about this up front.
荷兰还有几个人也在研究。简而言之，他们发现大脑网络模式可以将高度解离的人与那些患有我称之为“经典”或“单纯”PTSD（创伤后应激障碍）的人区分开来。所以现在在较新的诊断手册中，有解离性PTSD和常规PTSD。解离性患者，正如听起来的那样，当他们进入脑扫描仪时，例如，在扫描仪中听到他们的创伤故事被读给他们听。所以他们本质上是在经历闪回，并且事先得到了警告。
They're very brave and they do the studies, which helps us tremendously understand. stand, you know, traumatic brains. And what we see in the scanners is that some areas of the brain start shutting down, going offline, if you will. There's less connectivity there. There's less brain flow, those sorts of things. And there are different patterns of neural activation, different network patterns, different blood use patterns that distinguish these two types of trauma reactions. So one is an emotional aroused, as I was referring to earlier, sort of a jacked up, hyper-aroused, flooded state, and then the shutdown state. Well, people at DID can actually go back and forth between those states. Some personality states will remember the trauma and tend to be
他们非常勇敢，参与了这些研究，这极大地帮助我们理解创伤大脑。我们在扫描仪中看到的是，大脑的某些区域开始关闭，或者说“离线”。那里的连接性减少了，脑血流量减少了，诸如此类。存在不同的神经激活模式、不同的网络模式、不同的血液使用模式，这些区分了这两种类型的创伤反应。一种是情绪觉醒，正如我之前提到的，一种是高度紧张、过度觉醒、被情绪淹没的状态；另一种是关闭状态。DID患者实际上可以在这些状态之间来回切换。一些人格状态会记住创伤，往往是
much more of the hyper-aroused, highly flooded emotional states, and others will be really numbed out. May not even remember the trauma, and their brains look different. The group in the Netherlands has repeatedly brought in professional actors and tried to get the professional actors to imitate the brain scans, and they can't do it, which helps really validate that it's a genuine disorder. You can't just fake it. On psych testing, we can distinguish it, and in the brain scanners, we can distinguish it. So clearly, I mean, DID is in the DSM-5, But as you've just said, it's one of the more controversial diagnoses. And some researchers and clinicians really disagree with a lot of what you're saying right now,
处于过度觉醒、高度情绪淹没的状态，而另一些则会变得非常麻木。甚至可能不记得创伤，他们的大脑看起来也不同。荷兰的研究小组多次请专业演员来模仿脑扫描，但他们做不到，这确实有助于验证这是一种真正的疾病。你不能仅仅假装。在心理测试中，我们可以区分它；在脑扫描仪中，我们也可以区分它。显然，DID在DSM-5中，但正如你刚才所说，它是最具争议的诊断之一。一些研究人员和临床医生确实不同意你刚才所说的大部分内容，
that it's not caused by trauma, that it doesn't really exist. And clearly you disagree. Why is this such a fraught topic? To be brief, because I could go on. I don't think the listeners want that. It is an uncomfortable topic. the whole idea of child abuse that is profound is really distasteful. Nobody likes to think about it and know about it and hear about it.
认为它不是由创伤引起的，认为它并不真正存在。显然你不同意。为什么这是一个如此令人不安的话题？简而言之，因为我可以继续说下去。我不认为听众想听那个。这是一个令人不舒服的话题。关于严重虐待儿童的整个想法确实令人反感。没有人喜欢去想它、了解它、听到它。
You think that even sexual harassment, sexual assault, just in recent years, the Me Too movement have made it so much clear how much of that has been going on unknown to many and without a lot of awareness and suppressed by some of the people and powers. Like some of the people in power have done these things, right? So of course the same thing is going to be happening with children, right? Of course. But there are many who just don't want to know about that. And, you know, some of them have been accused of child abuse and some haven't.
你认为即使是性骚扰、性侵犯，仅仅在最近几年，#MeToo运动已经让人们清楚地看到，有多少此类事件在不为人知的情况下发生，没有引起足够的重视，并被一些权势人物压制。就像一些当权者做过这些事，对吧？所以当然，同样的事情也会发生在孩子身上，对吧？当然。但有许多人只是不想知道这些。而且，他们中有些人被指控虐待儿童，有些人则没有。
We've seen, you know, with the institutional betrayal, all the movements looking at how coaches and churches and scouting groups and there's been all sorts of institutions where youth have been abused for decades. So there's as a society, as humans, we don't want to know about trauma. People who've gone through trauma don't want to know about trauma. Part of PTSD, one of the required symptom clusters is avoidance disconnection, not knowing, not feeling. Amnesia is included in that PTSD symptom cluster.
我们已经看到，随着机构背叛，所有的运动都在审视教练、教会、童子军团体等各种机构，几十年来青少年在这些地方受到虐待。所以作为一个社会，作为人类，我们不想知道创伤。经历过创伤的人也不想知道创伤。作为PTSD的一部分，所需的症状群之一是回避、断开连接、不知道、不感觉。失忆症包含在那个PTSD症状群中。
And so it's human nature to not really want to think and know about awful stuff. Many listeners can probably relate to, you know, after a while hearing about the coronavirus, maybe after a while they just got sick of hearing about it and they just had to stop. Or after 9-11, seeing the planes crash again and again and again in media coverage, you just have to stop. Some people may start to feel that about the Ukrainian war. it's natural to after a while feel like I can't know anymore. In addition, when a lot of the controversy started,
所以，不想去思考和了解可怕的事情是人性。许多听众可能能感同身受，比如在听了很长时间关于冠状病毒的消息后，也许过了一段时间他们只是厌倦了听到它，不得不停止。或者在9-11事件后，在媒体报道中一遍又一遍地看到飞机坠毁，你不得不停止。有些人可能开始对乌克兰战争有这种感觉。过了一段时间，感觉“我无法再了解更多了”，这是很自然的。此外，当许多争议开始时，
we didn't have anywhere near the research we have now on the brain and the impact of trauma. And we didn't have all the research on dissociation around the world. And DID found around the world, even when it's not in the diagnostic manual, even where they never saw that movie Sybil. And so it's validated it. the fact that there are types of DID found in every single culture around the world where it's been
我们没有像现在这样对大脑和创伤影响的研究。我们也没有关于世界各地解离的所有研究。DID在世界各地被发现，即使它不在诊断手册中，即使他们从未看过那部电影《西比尔》。所以它被验证了。事实上，在世界各地每一个文化中，只要用标准化测量方法进行科学研究，都能发现DID。它看起来可能不同。例如，在一些东方国家，甚至在我们自己的国家，在美国的一些亚文化中，它通常被体验为“附体”。所以存在文化差异，但它存在于世界各地，就像虐待儿童存在于世界各地一样。最近有一些关于TikTok上的病毒式视频导致人们给自己诊断这种疾病的新闻。心理健康提供者应该如何回应？我听说过这件事，也咨询过其中一些案例，这是真的。这是一个我们必须非常慎重对待的问题，因为有些人是准确的
studied scientifically with standardized measures, they found it. It can look differently. For example, in some Eastern countries or even in our own, even in the United States, in some subcultures, it's often experienced as possession. So there are cultural variations, but it exists around the world, just like child abuse exists around the world. There have been some new stories lately about how some viral TikTok videos about DID have led to an uptick in people diagnosing themselves with a disorder. How should mental health providers respond to that? I have heard about this and I've been consulted on a number of these cases and it's true. It's an issue we have to be really thoughtful about because some people are accurately
自我诊断，而另一些人可能不准确。所以我再次回到科学和这些经过验证的测量方法。我敦促任何临床医生学习这些测量方法并使用它们，帮助客户理解他们的主诉是什么。我听说过一些与TikTok相关的案例，这些人确实没有凝聚的自我感。他们不了解自己。他们确实与他们所看到的一些东西产生共鸣，无论是DID还是其他，都有
self-diagnosing and then there's others that may not be accurate. And so I go again back to science and these validated measures. I urge any clinicians out there to learn about these measures and use them and help clients understand whatever they're presenting complaints are. Some of the cases I've heard about related to TikTok are individuals who really don't have a cohesive sense of themselves. They don't understand themselves. And they do relate to some of what they've seen, whether it's DID or not, there's
他们自身的一些方面听起来很相似。所以，临床医生有责任做好评估工作：这个人是否具备所有预期的共病症状？他们是否有那种创伤史？要深思熟虑并倾听。与我做过的一些研究不同，在那些研究中，一些患有DID的客户报告说，高达35%的人表示临床医生表现出轻蔑甚至直接的伤害，在某些情况下，甚至嘲笑并说“你在编造，这不是真的”。所以我敦促临床医生，显然不要伤害来寻求帮助的客户，而是使用
some aspects of who they are that sounds similar. And so it's really up to the clinician to do a good job of assessing, does the person have all the co-occurring or it's called comorbid symptoms you'd expect? Do they have that kind of trauma history? And to be thoughtful and listen, unlike in some of the studies I've done, where some clients who have DID have reported up to 35% report that a clinician has been dismissive or downright hurtful, in some cases, just laughed and said, you're making this up, this isn't real. So I urge clinicians, obviously, not to harm clients who are coming for help, but to use
循证测量工具来进行仔细、准确的评估过程。DID在人群中的估计患病率是多少？它略高于双相情感障碍和精神分裂症的患病率，这让人们感到震惊。在我们的普通人群研究中，它略高于1%。现在，我们需要更多的研究。这不是一个研究资金充足的领域，那种流行病学研究很昂贵，但它并不罕见。
evidence-based measures to do a careful, accurate assessment process. What is the estimated prevalence of DID in the population? It is slightly above the prevalence of bipolar disorder and schizophrenia, which shocks people. It's slightly above 1% in the general population studies that we have. Now, we need more studies. This is not an area that's been well funded in research, and that kind of epidemiological research is expensive, but it is not uncommon.
如果人们认为自己可能患有解离性障碍，无论是DID还是相关疾病，他们可以去哪里？是否有特殊的地方，或者他们应该寻找某种特定的从业者？是的。正如我刚才所说的，尝试寻找受过创伤相关障碍（包括解离）培训的人。有一个专业组织，我会慢慢说出它的名字。它是“国际创伤与解离研究学会”。
And where can people go if they think they might have a dissociative disorder, whether it's DID or something related? Is there someplace special, some particular kind of practitioner they should look for? Yes. So as I was saying earlier, try to locate somebody who's had training in trauma-related disorders, including dissociation. There's a professional organization, I'll say the name slowly. It's the International Society for the Study of Trauma and Dissociation.
缩写为ISSTD。如果你在网上搜索它，他们有一个网站。他们有各种各样的信息、常见问题解答。他们有一些问卷、临床医生可以访问的资源。他们还有治疗儿童和成人的治疗指南。对于心理健康专业人员、解离性障碍患者的亲人，或者认为自己可能患有此病的人来说，这是一个非常好的转诊、参考和资源空间。
It's abbreviated ISSTD. And if you just search for that online, they have a website. They have all sorts of information, frequently asked questions. They have some questionnaires, resources that clinicians can access. And they also have treatment guidelines for treating children as well as adults. It's a really good referral, reference, resource space for both mental health professionals as well as loved ones of somebody who has a dissociative disorder or an individual who thinks they might have one.
有哪些重大的未解之谜？如果你有选择权，我们现在应该关注和学习什么，以更好地理解DID。我有无限的资金吗？拜托，Kim。我想那是每个人的答案。我刚才提到，一些研究人员和我刚刚开始针对解离个体进行第一次随机对照试验，不仅仅是DID，但DID患者也被邀请并鼓励与他们的治疗师一起参加这项研究。所以这被称为TOP DD研究，你之前提到过。我们需要找出的是，这种标准化治疗
What are the big unanswered questions? If you had your druthers, what would we be looking at and learning now to better understand DID. Do I get unlimited funding? Please, Kim. I think that's everyone's answer. I were just now, some researchers and I are just now starting the first randomized controlled trial for the treatment of dissociative individuals, not just DID, but DID folks are invited and encouraged to come along and try out the study with their therapist. So that's called the top DD. study, you referenced it earlier, what we need to find out is, does that standardized treatment
是否能帮助个人？这只是针对治疗的初始阶段，即第一阶段。我们需要为治疗师开发针对多年治疗全过程（第一、二、三阶段）的标准化干预措施和培训。我们需要更多地了解解离性障碍的神经生物学。如果我们能找到一些方法来获得标记，比如生物标记，那就太棒了。包括哈佛研究人员Lauren LeBois和Melissa Kaufman在内的人们，他们正在研究可能像签名一样的生物标记，
help individuals? And that was just for the beginning phase, stage one of treatment. We need to develop standardized interventions and training for the therapist for the whole range across the years of treatment, stages one, two, and three. We need to learn a lot more about the neurobiology of dissociative disorders. And it would be fantastic if we can find some ways to have some markers, like a biological marker. And folks, including the Harvard researchers, Lauren LeBois and Melissa Kaufman, they are researching biological markers that might be like a signature,
严重解离的生物签名，这将极大地辅助评估过程。好吧，Brand博士，谢谢你。这真的非常引人入胜。我很感谢你今天抽出时间与我交谈。这很有趣。非常感谢邀请我。你可以在我们的网站www.spokenofpsycher上，或者在Apple、Stitcher或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。
a biological signature for serious dissociation, which would aid in the assessment process tremendously. Well, Dr. Brand, thank you. This has been really fascinating. and I appreciate your taking the time to talk to me today. It's been fun. Thank you very much for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.spokenofpsycher or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts.
如果你在Apple上收听，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Wynerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Condihan。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
And if you're listening on Apple, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您是在Apple上收听，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speaking of psychology at APA.org。Speaking of Psychology由Lee Wynerman制作。我们的音频编辑是Chris Condihan。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。